and now a continuing angle last night we
told you how some on the Left have begun
to attack anyone who offers thoughts and
prayers in the wake of this horrific
shooting well the political and media
elite are still at it
watch thoughts and prayers are not going
to stop the next mass shooting thoughts
and prayers didn't stop a trouble person
from buying assault grade weapons that
took the lives of 26 people in an
instant my colleagues right now are
doing a moment of silence in the house
of our presenters I respect the right to
do that and I myself have participated
in many of them but I can't do this
again I've been there too many moments
of silences now compare that to what
Sunday's hero Stephen Willeford had to
say about the role of faith I'm no hero
I am NOT I think my God my Lord
protected me and gave me the skills to
do what needed to be done
joining us now for reaction is Jerry
Falwell Jr president of Liberty
University Jerry you're a believer
you've been watching this play out over
the last 72 hours the horror the loss
the sacrifice the sadness the attacks on
prayer prayer your reaction to this I
just think it's shameful and
disrespectful to the families of the
victims for anybody to try to politicize
something like this I think we need to
love support pray for these for these
people for their families for the for
the friends of everyone involved and and
to keep them in our prayers I think
that's what we are supposed to do I
we've got 15,000 students here I'm not a
pastor Reverend but I'm president of
Liberty University they've all been
praying for all the families of the
victims we had one student who lost his
in-laws in the in the killing in in
Texas and he's he and his family are on
the way back from Okinawa right now to
to attend the funeral and it's it's it's
a time for for us to grieve with them
not to not to make try to make political
points when something like this happens
why are so many in the secular left
somebody in Hollywood you know they are
and somebody in politics why are they so
afraid of a public expression of faith
whether it's a sentiment expressed or a
tweet and a pray for the I mean you can
pray and also advocate for legislative
changes or pray and say gosh how did
this guy get a gun I mean you can do
both things or you could choose not to
pray but why are they so offended and
bothered by prayer Gerry I can't speak
for them I don't understand that at all
Laura I just know that our country was
built on a judeo-christian ethic and
it's it's something that all of us one
of the reasons this country has been
successful is because of that that ethic
because of the way our people have not
just been a great people but a good
people and they've lived by the
teachings of Jesus to love our neighbors
as ourselves and really that's the only
way to end evil acts like this you can
outlaw guns and evil is gonna the only
way but the only way to stop evil is to
change people's hearts and that's that's
that's just so Elementary so simple I
don't understand why anybody would think
that I'm making a gun illegal would stop
a criminal who's willing to murder
somebody else from buying a gun he had
the wherewithal Jerry to commit a
terrible horrible series of killings
here whether with the pressure cooker
bomb or with something else he had the
military training he could go on YouTube
watch the video and do it man he could
have done it
a brave neighbor who had the ar-15 who
stopped him if the guns were outlawed he
wouldn't have had a gun and who
how many other people would have been
killed I think the lesson from this this
shooting is that we need more good
people to have guns at every oh they're
gonna kill you for saying that
Jerry Jerry you say that and they're
gonna clip this tape they're gonna run
it on a late night show and they're just
gonna go bla bla bla bla bla then we get
people dead it's just common sense we at
liberty we have teachers who carry guns
with a concealed carry permit every
concert every sporting event every
church service should have a certain
number of people with concealed carry
permits with guns I know it searched
here locally all their Deacons carry
guns on Sunday morning and most most
mass shootings like this occur in
gun-free zones that's been true since
1950 this one's a little different but
it's unusual but that's the only way to
stop evil it takes place about eleven
minutes to respond and these shootings
are over in five minutes so I don't know
why that sucks it's to me it's common
sense I don't know why that's so
controversial
it's just Liberty we've we've we're
right now adding magnetometers to all
our events just like at an airport we're
bringing in dogs they've been dogs that
stuff I mean it's not next time you come
Nick next time you come back to Liberty
it's going to be a lot harder for for
you to get in and out Laura but it's
what we have to do that's that now that
is depressing but Jerry thank you for
spending some time with us tonight for
this perspective